Sleep is the elixir of life.
But we are a chronically
sleep deprived society.
And studies have shown us
that one in three people
don't get enough sleep.
As a neuroscientist
at UC Berkeley,
I am passionate about sleep.
So I have a mission.
I desperately want to reunite
humanity with Mother Nature's
best effort yet at immortality.
We often think of sleep as the
third pillar of good health
alongside diet and exercise.
But in truth, sleep is
actually the foundation
on which those two
other pillars will sit.
I'm going to share with
you the science behind what
will enhance your sleep,
why it's important,
and how proper sleep
can benefit your life.
In the brain during deep
sleep, hundreds of thousands
of brain cells in your cortex
fire together and then they all
go silent together.
In fact, some parts of
your brain are up to 30%
more active when you go into REM
sleep than when you are awake.
Your brain and your body need
to drop their core temperature
in order for you to fall asleep
and then stay asleep soundly
across the night.
So set your bedroom temperature
to about 68 degrees Fahrenheit.
And using sleep trackers, it
gives us a historical record
of our sleep, and
they may become
the ultimate secret
sleep weapon.
I believe it is time
to reclaim our right
to a full night of sleep and the
opportunity for a better life.
It is never too late to
start sleeping better.
I'm Matthew Walker, and
this is my MasterClass.
[MUSIC PLAYING]